hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and welcome back to my Channel
today I'm going to talk about orderflow
gaps orderflow gaps is one of the new
tools that we've added to the orderflows
trader 7 software you know we released
it about a week ago and Traders have
just been telling me they're there're
they're Blown Away with the capabilities
now of analyzing order flow um and one
of the
tools is the orderflow gaps and I going
to show you um how to use it because you
know I get a lot of emails for people
say Mike you know I just want to scalp
um you know a few
ticks several times a day you know is
there something that I can use well
there's a lot of things in the orderflow
if that's your method of trading your
sort of your your style of trading where
you're trying to scalp a few ticks here
and there multiple times during the day
and hopefully you know order flow gaps
is um one of those tools that you could
add to your trading now you will need of
course the orderflows trader software
which runs on ninja Trader 8 now before
I begin you know if you enjoy my videos
be sure to hit the Subscribe button
and like the video you know if you get
something valuable out of the video be
sure to leave a comment below um all
right so this is Mees this is a one
minute chart and I'll just show you
really quick the orderflows gaps tool
right so it's part of the orderflows
trader 7 package and you scroll down you
you're going to open up the indicator
settings and you're going to find it in
here orderflow gaps okay
now to enable it just click the button
there I've made it a little bit darker I
think the default is set to 20 for the
color opacity I said it's to 50 so it's
a little easier to see in this video and
I I'll show you here really quick now
this is going to show all the gaps on
the chart okay and
while it's nice to see all of them you
don't really not going to use all of
them really okay so you see there's Gap
here Gap here here Gap here um because
you know when think about Gap trading
right when when you think in terms of
Gap trading you're usually looking for a
market
to um break
out of of a move or or um the way I like
to look at gaps is as reversals um you
know when a market hits a low then
there's a gap you know sort of to the
upside to me that that's telling me that
there's strong buying that's taking
place okay or if the market had rallied
then there's a gap to the downside that
you know a move lower can happen
so while it's nice to see all the gaps
on here because again you know this is a
Mees chart and you know the way honestly
the way equities have been trading the
last couple years
it's not a fun Market to trade know
there's a lot of other easier markets I
think to to trade than
um the stock indices okay and I'll get
to that in a second but what you could
do is we have a feature on here to
filter out the signals to come in in at
swing highs and swing
lows okay and and what that's going to
do is it's going to give you
more I say more accurate but it's going
to give you trades that have more of a
potential if it's going to be you know a
reversal off of a low or reversal off of
a high more opportunity okay so I'll
just enable
that and click okay so now it's going to
show me when there's a gap at a swing
high or a gap at a swing low so just
just go back here okay so all right so
this was the cash close
here here it just went sideways okay
fine
sideways
stopped you out but then there's a nice
bullish one here skinny one all right
but again this is a move from 38 all the
way up to 50 you know that's a 12-point
move right so even if you get stopped
out once twice even you know a third
time you just had a 12-point move here
okay again those a little bit lower not
much again that one would have stopped
you
out nothing
small move up
here a little move down a little move up
right a little move up there's move
down okay this one now that probably
would stopped you
out and then going back from the cash
open I mean look at this right off the
cash open we're talking a move from you
know 70 all the way up to 90s that's a
20 point move so even though you had a
few that did nothing and probably
stopped you out
during the day it did capture a few of
the nice moves during the day now again
what I was alluding to earlier with
markets that are in my opinion a little
bit easier to trade with orderflow um
things like the currencies right Euro
currency now whether you're using a
minute base chart you could I think for
currencies you know you could use a time
uh tick based chart either you four five
or even eight range
chart right well this one is right on
the close but here look at this move if
you just had one trade this day on the
euro currency right
from this Gap in here you know you of
course it's not going to confirm that
there's a gap here until this bar closes
but you know you're talking to move from
57 all the way down into the 40s below
there little move up here move down
nice move
down nice move up again that's on an
eight range if even if you're on a a
quicker chart a for range chart you know
move up move down move up nice move down
nice move up sideways little move
up you know move down this one went
sideways you nice little move up there
nice move down um you know British
pound also for range you know people ask
you know what's what's the best chart to
trade you know is it a range based chart
you know if it is um you know what type
of range you know if you're using this
is a four range chart but you know you
could use a four range you could use a
five range
um you know because really what you're
looking at is at swing highs right here
here here right so even if you know this
one would not have stopped yall cuz we
didn't get get it as higher as this bar
here but even if you did get stopped out
here you had this last trade here to
make it all back here's a nice short
here there another nice short
here okay again that's that's a five
range chart
um you even if you're on a minute base
chart I don't know what the minute base
chart looks like but let's take a look
here here's a nice little move up
here
another move
up a move down that's not far that's
when the number came out
here but that's a nice move down
um you know even you know bonds or Ultra
bonds again I wouldn't use a minute base
chart on Ultra bonds for bonds I always
look at the market through a uh range
based chart but here's a nice move up
here nice move up here here this one
didn't give you much of anything but a
nice move down here right that's Ultra
bonds um well regular
bonds
okay this about 5 minutes after the 7
minutes after non-farm payrolls got a
nice move up little move up little move
down little move
up there so again yeah that's this is
during the number data is coming out so
fast ninja Trader can even keep up with
it um but uh yeah this is the uh
tool all right orderflow gaps here it's
part of the Ninja tra it's part of the
orderflows trader uh
software where is it here orderflow gaps
here right
here okay okay
so you know now that I'm getting my
voice back I sort of got over this bad
flu I'm getting a little bit better um
I'll get more videos out there for you
guys to show you some of these different
tools that are on the order flow
illustrator 7 okay but again one of my
favorites is this one it's the orderflow
gaps you know is that it's a great tool
if if you're into the currencies um
especially if you're just you know
looking for short quick moves um use it
with the default setting but use it with
the swing filter enabled all right
everyone Thanks for catching this video
I'll catch you on the next one take care
bye-bye